fight in the way of Allah against those
who fight you so what did Robert Spencer
say nothing but truth comes from me you
can always have honesty on my part
everything I tell you is the truth okay
so you are a liar a big fat liar
do you want to speak with confidence
like these amazing personalities every
single one of these amazing speakers
have taken the same program with brother
Muhammad arshad Muhammad arshad has
helped develop all of us it's extremely
beneficial to do this course definitely
recommend this course
to access the free life-changing
training
brothers and sisters and dear friends
I'm going to debunk Robert Spencer and
his big lies he was using machine gun
tactic against Prophet Daniel and Jay
and I don't blame brother Daniel and
Jake for not addressing these issues
because they were throwing Left Right
Center so many other issues and handling
the debate turned out to make them look
like absolute emotional wrecks and the
whole world saw that and they saw how
two Muslims were defending the Bible
more than the Christians themselves
which was amazing so if I look at the
comments and we do another reaction for
the comments
um now in this video we're going to go
straight to the verse listen to what
Robert had to say the marching orders
for today whereas people read the Quran
Unfortunately they do think that when it
says kill them wherever you find them
when you meet the unbelievers strike the
next and so on and so on they do believe
that these things are marching orders
for today because the current so there
you go guys what does he quote he goes
straight to the verse which is saying
what and kill them wherever you find
them
stop okay Carry On speaking no let's get
context here let's just give context
quickly okay Allah says in the Quran
fight in the way I'll fight in the way
of Allah against those who fight you so
what did Robin sponsors say nothing but
truth comes from me you can always have
honesty on my part everything I tell you
is the truth okay so you are a liar a
big fat liar and we're gonna expose you
so what does the verse say the verse
before it fight in the way of Allah
against those who fight you and do not
transgress very Allah does not like the
transgressive understand this as what
that you do not transgress in the way of
killing men innocent women children and
babies whether for that matter and if
you look into the Bible I challenge
Robert Spencer and Rashid hamam the
toilet guy I challenge you to show me a
single verse like the verse in the Bible
that was prescribed not description
prescribed okay not descriptive
prescriptive that Jesus said the god of
the Old Testament Go and Kill men women
children babies and donkeys I challenge
them to find the single verse in the
Quran and the Hadith that is word for
word the same they could never now what
is the following verse say and kill them
wherever you find them who the
mushrikeen the Pagan Arabs nowhere does
that ever tell you not a single scholar
or anyone for that matter have ever
understood that as your general
non-muslim public this is talking about
verses of War very categorically clear
and it's talking about the Pagan Arab
Idol worshipers who were persecuting the
Muslims for over 23 years and if you go
to Surah Hajj I'll in verse 40 if I'm
not mistaken Allah says permission to
fight has been given to those who have
been fought after nearly 13 years of
persecution now what does the following
verse say
kill them wherever you find them who if
we are going to work against the Germans
and the British army says to the Germans
to the British soldiers wherever you
find the Germans kill them would that be
controversial would that be violent
would that tell the British soldiers
that wherever you find innocent Germans
no they would say wherever you find the
Germans kill them yes because they are
coming for war not wherever you find
them give them a kiss there you go and
then the verse says what and drive them
out from where they drove you out you
can always have honesty on my part
everything I tell you is the truth okay
does that not show self-defense Robert
Spencer you liar you've been exposed so
there you go guys very clearly and let's
carry on for fitna is for fitna to
create this order is is more severe than
killing meaning for someone to corrupt
cause Crush in the land that's going to
cost the lives of many people and
Corruption and disorder in the land it
is better that one individual or those
individuals are gotten rid of then
massive disorder being caused that's
going to affect millions of other people
but Robert Spencer didn't say that
because he's a liar however do not fight
them
unless they fight you there so Allah
saying do not fight them in a specific
location if they fight you then fight
them back which is self-defense unless
they fight you there if they fight you
there and surely kill them surely is the
reward of disbelievers now verse 192
listen carefully guys but if they desist
if they stop then indeed Allah is most
forgiven well I thought we was
aggressive so why is the verse saying if
they stopped but I thought we Muslims
were supposed to be you know
spontaneously and just attacking
non-muslims just because they're not
Muslims it says if they stop meaning if
they stop attacking you then leave them
alone you can always have honesty on my
part everything I tell you is the truth
this debunks the whole claim of Robert
Spencer that as Muslims we oh I wake up
and I go how can I where's the where's
the disbelievers my neighbors all my
neighbors I've got about 13 14 Neighbors
yallah
this is this is clear that Robert
Spencer is a liar now and the final
verse 193 is what fight them unto there
is no fitna anymore and obedience
remains for Allah but if they desist
then aggression is not allowed except
against the transgressors against the
transgressives and fight them until
there is no fit in the fitness of
attacking persecuting the Muslims Etc
why because their freedom of speech of
just calling people to Islam that's
their only crime that's what they say
until the obedience is only for God
Almighty the Sharia is just legislation
okay this is what Allah is saying and if
they desist aggression is only for him
against the transgresses well this
doesn't make sense I thought we was a
transgresses so we have been told do not
fight them on this they fight you and
transgressions against only those who
will transgress you can always have
honesty on my part everything I tell you
is the truth okay so it makes it
categorically clear that nowhere in the
Quran does it ever ever tell Muslims
that you have to go out of your way and
attack non-muslim civilians immensely
people going down about their life and
guess what you know who else should have
been on the side of Russian hamam the
toilet and Robert Spencer baghdadi yes
the yes the head leader of Isis yes he
should be on their side you know why
because he would have agreed every
single word that's coming out of Russian
hamam's mouth and Robert Spencer's that
is all I have to say guys and you can
see how they got debunked instantly and
this is why they are liars and this
shows you clearly and categorically that
the Muslims were never
instructed to fight the disbelievers
just just because they are disbelievers
that is an absolute lie you can always
have honesty on my part everything I
tell you is the truth okay so next time